us getting acknowledgement from somebody
we admire
has always been a human trait and i
think texting and replying
there's a level of even more oomph i
mean people go crazy and are excited
when somebody likes
their post when they get a dm it's all
time in text it's all time all time
at least in the current state
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
welcome to c2 this first virtual
iteration of c2 i'm a montrealer
i'm shira lazar and was at c2 last year
in person so it's great to be involved
again
from venice california basically in my
my bedroom makes it i guess a bit easier
i also want to say hi to everyone
joining from around the world let us
know where you're from
in the chat although i'm very sad that i
can't be home so this is like this is
good but it would be nice to
be home with my family and all of you
right now but this is good enough of
course
with that said audience interaction is
at the core of the c2
experience so i encourage you to submit
your questions for gary on the right
hand side of your screen
i'll be asking some of these questions
towards the end of the session
so thank you again for joining us and
interacting as well
gary it is so great to see you in these
crazy circumstances
right now here at c2
it's great to see you shira thank you so
much to everybody at c2
i am also pretty devastated c2 has
always
fallen in that first weekend in may
which has always been my mom's birthday
weekend and my mom is
my mom and my hero so i never travel in
that weekend so for about seven or eight
years i've dreamed
of doing c2 when it first kind of hit my
radar about a decade ago
i had have been invited in the past
was devastated that i could never really
make it logistically work
so under these wild circumstances uh i'm
glad to be here but i am
i'm hurting a little bit because some of
the restaurant you know i grew up in the
wine
business and the restaurant at wine
scene in montreal is something i admire
very much so
i too wish i was there exactly well
we'll have to have a
a drink in person hopefully at a certain
point soon but i just want to ask you
this because i'm asking a lot of people
this when i interview them right now
how are you doing i'm doing well
you know i i you know uh the reality is
and and it's really fun to do this with
you sure because we've known each other
a long long time and have been through
this journey together
i think you know me which is you know
i i'm a simple dude in a lot of ways i'm
a
i'm i'm very out there but i'm quite
small and private in my actual real life
and what i mean by that is
as long as the 15 people i love the most
in the world
and then call it the next 100 or so
closest friends in the world
luckily that graph has gone through this
process so far with a bunch of
health and nothing that it has really
caused
deep despair and and you know my
business challenges which have been
substantial this year
are just not i don't even know i'm known
to everybody in this audience
i'm sure the people that know me in this
audience as an entrepreneur
and of course in public that's what i
talk about
it's a very distant second to how i live
my life
and what i mean by that is business
struggles
are just so not important in a world
where you know
millions of people have lost their life
prematurely during this pandemic and i
think
we you know people going through war or
tragedy
they become accustomed to their reality
i don't take it lightly that i've been
able to navigate so far through this
pandemic
with the people i love the most being
healthy and so
when you ask me how i'm doing i'm doing
great because that thing's in place
as far as business you know and
creativity and all the things we'll talk
about here
there's plenty of challenges but in a
lot of ways i like being an entrepreneur
and i think that the wartime the
tough times of entrepreneurship for me
in a little weird way are
interesting and come and i'm i enjoy the
tough times
the 911s the great recessions the
the pandemic from a business standpoint
obviously those are horrific things but
from a business standpoint i'm up for
the challenge
and i've been very focused to try to
lead my organizations and
um and so that's what i'm focusing on
the optimism of it
well i appreciate that transparency
because i think people see you and they
see that like yeah the hustle and the
winds it's always it feels like a lot of
success and
for you to share that yeah it's been
challenging business-wise and i've had
some failures can you get into some
of those i guess failures and the
lessons you've learned from them or how
you've navigated that
you know our vayner you know vaynermedia
is the company that most people know if
they even know me outside of
you know i always laugh with people like
he's a motivational speaker i'm like man
i need to do better
job branding because because i spent 98
of my time running a thousand person
global company
you know the lesson learned i'll go
backwards is
something i've always known but it's
always a great reminder which is
you are not in control vayner
productions
our production company and and boehner
speakers our speaking bureau
were incredibly in place
to have tremendous years because
of the work we did in 2019 both have
gone to zero basically
because there's just no way to navigate
this reality
so that's happened that's been a
challenge it's tough to stand up
businesses
that are losing lots of money it's what
you sign up for
uh vaynermedia the core business had a
lot of clients
push out their payment terms um cancel
business go out of business
that led to the part that most breaks my
heart which is
you know 80 70 80 employees over a
four-month period had to be furloughed
and let go
i know these people you know i know that
their mom is sick i know that they've
been here for five years
it's it's so lonely and especially
because i don't hide so
my company knows every decision goes
through my desk
every thing that's a problem is my fault
accountability
is something that the world really
doesn't like
to do right now but i think it is a
liberator
and so when when when somebody reaches
out can i talk to you after they've been
let go
they've been with you for six and a half
years and you know that they
know that you signed off on them being
let go
that is as uncomfortable as it gets uh
i've learned
here's something that i think is going
to really bring value to the audience i
hope
even if it's from one person on stage
i am unbelievably candorous right
gary i love your no [ __ ] style in
real life
and again sure it's fun to do this with
you because you have a
you know you know me a little bit more
than most people because we've spent
time at south by and different things
i i'm i'm very soft
as like a human which means
my greatest shortcoming as a
professional
has been candor believe it or not to my
employees
and so through this period i've leaned
into candor
and it's it's helped me and so i've
learned the value of candor
i view candor now as kindness i used to
view candor
as being mean i really did i didn't have
a good relationship with candor
i looked at it as like hurting
somebody's feelings and i was so
talented in business that i would be
like i'll put this on my back
but what i was doing was not
communicating
building resentment and then eventually
firing which caught people off guard
and led to it probably the so i'm very
i've learned candor during this time or
or i've taken my candor game from a two
to six during this period
which i really enjoy and them and i'm
aiming for eight or nine
it seems like having uncomfortable
conversations and not just on stage and
on social media but like
in person which is actually more
intimate and real right
you know just can't you know on stage
i'm talking to the world
i'm talking in the macro yeah you know
why why do i like q a and please
everybody who's watching get very
detailed with any of the
questions you have in in q a in real
life you go
micro you go detailed and so on stage
when i'm telling you
hey the world you know don't worry about
your parents opinion
that's right to lead to happiness and
lack of resentment
you know but in real life when ricky
loves his parents
it's it gets much harder it's easier
said than done
i want to i love this and this is like
the personal growth gary that i love to
see
um but i a lot of people here are
obviously marketing and in media
and i they're also i think there's a lot
of now we're all entrepreneurs
in a way even if we work with a big
company you could say the
division is can be like a startup um you
probably see so much and get pitched so
much how do you know when something is
worth taking on or moving into as an
industry or project like what's your
filter
including right now um my filter is
really
um my personal opinion
based on data or intuition around actual
consumer behavior
i think my career has gone really well
because um
i don't over complicate things do people
use this
how do people like it do i understand
how it can grow
and so facebook twitter tumblr
you know venmo those investments were
really thoughtful and i did quite well
and that was around the time we'd
started to know each other in those
early mid 2000s
south by era those were common sense
investments by me
i knew that they were good platforms i
knew people were using them i could see
where this was going the mobile device
was something i bet on so it made sense
um
the thing i learned after i made those
good investments the next tier of bad
investments
the thesis were right made but the
entrepreneurs weren't strong
what was different about 2003 456 was
a kevin rose a travis a a mark
zuckerberg
you know a tara hunt these people were
actually
entrepreneurs and technology had come
as entrepreneurship exploded and money
started coming in you had a lot of
people that were executives
or worse nightlife promoters you know
kind of just like
coming in and thinking they could build
billion dollar tech companies
and where i got caught was i liked the
thesis
but i misunders i would look through the
lens of if i ran the company
and there were great companies and even
good entrepreneurs gowalla highlight
some of these things that you know
really were great
what the miss was the entrepreneur's
ability even if they were strong in the
case of those two companies
to really navigate the business to be a
business
and so i learned a lot in that era so
today what i look at is the jockey and
the horse
do i like the horse the app the idea the
business do i like the thesis
do i believe that people are going to
eat healthier and those
foods are going to do well yes but i'm
spending a lot more time looking at the
jockey
is this just a great you know student
that went to mcgill or harvard
or brown and just has a great resume but
are they actually an entrepreneur
do they have patience are they just good
at raising capital or are they good at
leading men and women
you know is she capable of pivoting when
it doesn't work rachel
you know rachel to you know at at
at mcmack is his investment i'm involved
in and for everybody in e-commerce you
should check out mcmac
i knew rachel was capable it's an
e-commerce platform
for omni-channel brands if you sell on
target and walmart
and your own dtc and on instagram it's a
it's a sas business that really makes
that effective
i knew that she would pivot and she
started as a qvc of mobile
and now she's a she's a sas product that
is enabling the biggest brands in the
world
to win on e-commerce that's a big pivot
i saw that in her eyes
that's what i'm looking for the jockey
and the horse
i love that how do you come into an
already in a dated space and make a mark
or do you and this is i could go for
entrepreneurship or brands yeah
you out perform you know absolutely
right you know like
going into the car industry is hard but
if tesla makes a better product and
navigates better it can win
actually you know what's really funny
that you said that i've been thinking a
lot about search engines lately
i have this weird almost like out of
body
feeling that google could be disrupted
well they're they have an anti-trust
issue right now so
fair enough and uh to be honest with you
i'm under-educated on that and
and wasn't the premise the premise was
yeah i know
you know that it just has been the
leader for a long time
right you know like apple with the
mobile like why
can't bmw or tesla or or
or instagram come out with a hardware
phone
um i i just or something left field two
young gals in
in berlin just are hardware geniuses i
think people get
caught i made a lot of smart decisions
money business success on understanding
that people looked at print
and radio and television and they put it
on a pedestal and they didn't see
facebook and google
i now am actually starting to feel that
facebook and google
and and apple are now the vulnerable and
i'm kind of getting excited for
who wants to go like who's going to make
the greatest tv set that's fully
integrated for shopping like
they're just feel i don't know what it
is but kind and
my hairs are going up my back right now
i think some of the biggest things we
know
are on the precipice of being disrupted
or things like microsoft i mean i'm very
i'm very impressed by microsoft the last
two years three years with their new ceo
just being more contemporary making good
macro decisions linkedin
tripling down on gaming like so those
are the things running through my mind
you can you can out
you can disrupt by just outperforming
i mean and that's that's well said um
and then i think also understanding
those communities like not coming in
like if you're coming into tick tock
it's already
there's a lot going on you need to be
embedding yourself and having
people oversee that project who are in
that community i think also that's where
companies make mistakes sometimes
for sure and look you're an early mover
you and i talked about musically in
tik-tok three years ago
right so you've had a career youtube and
you and i with video youtube viddler
those days
you've always had a strong knack at
understanding where the
consumer's attention was early so you've
been able to now
you know we're not as young as we used
to be shira so we've we've now had
someone else
speak for myself i was trying to set up
i was trying to set up for
this thing anyway i you know i think
that i think that
what you've seen is you're exactly right
and the flip side there's just different
dynamics the greatest commercial that
ocean spray has ever made
was made by dog face you know for them
so you just have all these
dynamics of creative you know back to
the macro context of this festival yeah
i think
being an entrepreneur is actually wildly
creative if you're an entrepreneur
i think a lot of people view themselves
as entrepreneurs but what they are is
operators
they're very good at excel sheet finance
raising capital
and so i think inherently
entrepreneurship is one of the most
creative things of all time
because everything is a blank canvas
everything's a black canvas for me
i'm always looking at angles of like the
the not yet established because that is
always where
the most excitement is and i think a lot
of people watching right now can
resonate with that statement
yeah and speaking of tick tock because i
want to get into some platforms that
right now are hot but where do we see
them
maybe in a year to even more than that
so with tick tock being
very politicized even almost shut down
where do you think it is headed in the
next year from now should people be
putting their efforts
into that i think that putting your
efforts into something's always
fascinated me
because when seinfeld or mash
or or the cosby show were the number one
show on television people ran
commercials
right when sports illustrated was the
biggest magazine or
vogue you ran print i have no emotion if
facebook twitter linkedin instagram
snapchat disappear tomorrow
i care that today they have an
extraordinary amount of attention on
them
and communicating organically or through
paid
media amplification of creative is a
very effective and efficient way
and so listen i did damage on
damage meaning let me use my own slag i
have to define it sometimes i was able
to build awareness and growth on vine
on social cam on clerk on viddler
those things don't exist anymore and
that's okay
facebook used to be the my facebook fan
page was my
was my religion 48 months ago
i haven't even thought about it in the
last month
you know which is actually something i'm
trying to change you know and so yeah
how do you know
like gary how do you know when to stop
those things i think that people are
like i don't want to stop because then
i'll get out of the algorithm like
when do you know to take breaks on those
platforms when you're not happy you know
it's funny
even when you said hustle earlier when i
talk about work ethic aka hustle
i talk about it from a happiness filter
i've been very sad that people have
tried to bucket me into like
hustle porn or burnout i really have
because if you look at every word out of
my mouth
not the energy in which i deliver it but
the words i've talked about
it's about the happiness of your process
it's a very this is a very big deal to
me so the answer to your question is is
when do you stop something when you're
not happy
if you're opening twitter and your ex i
don't care how well you're winning on
twitter business-wise
you need to find a different
relationship with a different platform
or
re-assess your relationship with the
platform
that's what that is the main reason you
should stop the second reason is if you
don't have unlimited resources and time
you need to look at the platforms that
are most achieving what you want
whether that is money whether that is
happiness hopefully happiness over money
whether that is awareness growth that
you may later use for happiness
whether that's raising money for your
pta running for mayor
selling a sneaker you have to reverse
engineer what you're about
for me this is oh you know and you know
again something you know and i keep
referencing this because
there's not that many people that
actually know me more than what they see
online
you know the reason south by worked for
me is and you've seen it the reason
there was a secret wine party is
i love people the reason social media
for me is i love
people i love spending hours in in
comments and replying
the reason community the app works for
me is i like texting people
two one two nine three one five seven
three one you know and so like
i like people so it's worked for me but
if you don't
don't force yourself or if the platform
started off fun for you
instagram because it was photography but
now it's influencer life and you don't
like it
you don't have to you what you have to
do is force yourself
to debate how happy you are you don't
have to do anything
other than try to start strive for that
because it really matters
but then if you have a company in the
end you need to just overcome that hump
and say like this is what i need to do
to build my company um yes i'm a fan of
being able to create skin to deal with
adversity
but but i see a lot of people that have
a three million dollar a year business
go for five and love it at three
and hate it at five what i think people
need to do
is try to find a financial happiness
graph and then
live their lives within those
so to me what i think a lot about is you
know
yes there's things you have to do but
there but a lot of times people feel
they have to do something for their
business
because they have a bmw and a fancy
house
and they want to buy a six thousand
dollar pair of shoes
my debate in that analogy is hey maybe
if you didn't spend money on things that
are closing the gap of your happiness
and actually lived within the mean of a
business or
a job that makes you happy and you lived
within those means
maybe then you could have a very healthy
circle instead of what i see a lot which
is people's
think success is money and then they
start buying things because they
actually need those things to cover up
their unhappiness
and it becomes this official vicious
circle i think this is about
managing your own p l you know not
getting too into debt it's why i worry
about college a lot
college for a lot of people brings no
actual value financially
maybe spiritually or happiness or fun
times or memories
and what it does is it starts them off
in a place where they have to strive for
money
and they they're never able to get out
of that mistake and they're 42 years old
still in debt and live the life doing
something they didn't love
but they thought they had to do it to
pay down their debt
yeah it gets people started in scarcity
yeah you're saying really resonates and
but like i could get into that but i'm
not going to get into it too much but i
think that hopefully everyone on a
personal and professional level has
taken something from that because i do
think that
money brings anxiety and the minute you
take that anxiety out and you simplify
there's actually a lot of freedom in
including creative freedom that's where
creativity can
thrive um and so i want to you know
because we do have a lot of real quick
yep real quick you know what yeah i
think when you look
under the hood of pure entrepreneurship
those women and men
love the process i was 34 years old
before i made a video
i just loved building my dad's liquor
store for him i loved
it and and entrepreneurship and
creativity have become convoluted
a little bit and people think it's about
money
and the demonization of that is
unfortunate but i understand it
because a lot of people do go in there
with a very unhealthy
starting point but i think when you get
back to process and enjoyment
of it you know if you know this is why i
still garage sale
i actually enjoy it people make fun of
me on my couch i know i can't believe
that
i am amazed like so so you're doing the
garage sales you have your
cards right now which is mine going
um is there a business around cards like
should companies be like i'm going to
make a card now because there's a huge
business around that yeah
there's moments around cards and you
know i i think pokemon is some of the
most creative stuff and
and yeah i think you you watch trends
and do i think that like
influencers should think about starting
their own card lines and do i think
brands should yes i do and then by the
way
like pogs like cards like like you know
like
fashion sometimes jeans are low and
baggy other times they're tight and high
like
it just evolves and if you're not signed
up for the
evolution of creativity well then you
might as well
change your profession so what platforms
should people be looking at right now
and then
you know looking out to for the next
year
or so or two years to start like
investing in
or um you know putting their time into
that
or trends that like so if there's
platforms that come up yeah
yeah i think i've become more thoughtful
in this answer i'm pretty excited about
answering this because i think i have a
a nice way to break it down i want to
break it down into organic
and paid when i hear what platforms
should be paying attention to i used to
answer blindly
and i didn't give an answer blindly i
gave the current state but i didn't
break down this point that i think this
will help a lot of people
if you're talking about organic not
running social media ads
to achieve whatever you want then you
got to talk tic talk and linkedin
because those are the two platforms
where you can get organic reach every
person here
with no audience can go make a video a
picture a written word
post it on those platforms and start
building audience
because there's still not enough content
to fill the pipes
of the consumption if you're talking ads
now you talk instagram snapchat youtube
pre-roll
facebook's a monster especially if
you're targeting 45 to 90 year olds
instagram stories and instruments
well sure there's a lot of businesses to
sell to 90 year olds oh my god our 90
year olds even on facebook
90 year olds dominate facebook facebook
zero yes 9-0 sure one day you'll be 9-0
and you're gonna want to be on the
facebook at the time because you're
going to care about your granddaughter
and you're going to get out of this and
you're going to care about
issues and and memories and connecting
with i love it
from 60 years ago um yeah i mean i so
anyway nonetheless
it's an organic and paid split organic
for everybody out there with
not the means to run media it's tick
tock and linkedin
media it's really heavy facebook
instagram
tick tock itself also has a great ad
product linkedin does as well actually
if you're trying to sell b2b
but to pre-roll then the chasm opens up
because then they all become
underpriced if you really know how to
media plan inside of them
because right now the biggest companies
in the world still don't spend enough
on social media platform marketing which
means the ads are underpriced in
comparison to programmatic digital
or print or radio or television but do
you see
um brands wanting to have a more like
holistic spend so
they'll go to an agency and say okay we
want you to handle all of it
like it'll be the tv prince
out of home social or do you think you
see it still as
divided it goes both ways you know i'm
very proud of where vayner media is we
came from
community management and social to now
doing three super bowl spots last year
full creative aor for scots where the
media and creative aor
like the mad men era so we've um we've
definitely evolved
up and i think that some of the great
iconic creative shops
are are in need of coming down
because when they think of social
creative and media as an afterthought a
nice to have or that silly little thing
that's not as important as this
creative thing up here it's going to
make them quite vulnerable in the next
decade
yeah what do you think of texting
platforms like you mentioned community
that you're on
how can uh brands and companies use that
i mean i launched something for my dad
called wine text
anybody who buys wine please sign up for
wine text um
that has transformed his business in 18
months has literally brought the
business back to the levels of when i
was there in my prime
wow so i think text as using text
the way we use email is showing results
like the late 90s
huge open rates huge engagement huge
conversion
we'll ruin it like we did with email
over the next decade hopefully we learn
from email
and we don't just make it spam offer
offer offer offer
yeah what's the strategy around that so
you don't troll people because like i
feel like but i'm a bit older so getting
texts as like promotion or from brands
it's weird to me
because it's such a personal feed not
not if it brings you extraordinary value
right the reason why texts work for
example is we're selling 80
wine for 30 dollars period of the story
and so
because we only have to offer 365 wines
a year we're using our buying power
we're throwing a huge buying team at it
and we're we're able to get that
and so it's not going to be weird if you
get your favorite product
for just unfortunately better price
there you go like it's
about you though but like you're
everywhere how are you making your brand
different over text
i'm replying and something about the
intimacy
of getting versus
versus adia sure when i tell you
that if randy the macho man savage
texted me back in 1987
i'd i'd still be talking about it heck
i'm making pretend it happened right now
and i'm still talking about it
when you care about somebody and they
text you back
and it's not a bot that gets exciting
and i think we all
appreciate an acknowledgement a wink a
head nod
a looking up when they signed a book and
saying hi
uh whenever the us getting
acknowledgement from somebody we admire
has always been a human trait and i
think texting and replying
there's a level of even more oomph i
mean people go crazy and are excited
when somebody likes their post
when they get a dm it's all time in text
it's all time
all time at least in the current state
of communication
we're about to get to your questions and
please continue to
include them in the comments in the chat
um
what industries are interesting to you
right now as an investor
i apologize one more time what
industries are interesting to you right
now as an investor
direct to consumer brands that are
actually sustainable and aren't just
good at
internet cac and ltv numbers but are
actually holistic in building brand and
building macro ltd
i think every category soap glasses
toothbrushes
rings every single category will have
winners over the next 20 years
in the consumer product plan anything
you buy at a costco
or a saints berry or a walmart or
any big store around the world will be
will every product in those stores
convenience stores
every product in those stores will
become something that goes direct to
consumers so there's unbelievable
amounts of
opportunity there i think the other
thing that really is interesting to me
is voice
i'm very high on voice ai alexa google
home apple
home but i think those things are going
to play out over the next decade
so that's a little early but i'm
watching it very carefully because i
think humans
the reason i bet on this was because
people don't like friction the reason
i'm gonna bet on voice is people don't
like friction
hey alexa send me pizza that's fast
that's fast
and that will be real life somebody's
gonna play that out
um it may not be the way we see it now
it might come through a phone it might
be closed that
has a loop it might be a hat it might be
glasses it might be the paint
that is smart paint in your home i don't
know who wins the voice game
but i know the voice game will be one
because it's faster than grabbing your
phone
and doing it on your phone and speaking
and that always will yeah
and then and you said it's too early so
i'm gonna wait and see at what point
then do you come watch
me when when something hits you know
it's the same you know i watched
friendster and myspace
and then it was like wait a minute this
is happening with facebook
that's when i hit social media i've two
years ago i went to
amazon's techstars incubator around
building apps on
alexa meeting people talking about it in
public
i say it here three people email me gary
vaynermedia.com
hey i heard you say this at c2 i'm doing
this
take the meeting take the meeting meet
the kid meet the person meet the og
then be educated then hit when i feel
it's time
so it seems it can't can it be ever
tiring like do you ever get tired
how much sleep do you get and we're
going to get to the questions i just
wanted to ask this because
i just want to understand how you yeah
your morning routine like what do you do
i slept two days ago i slept 10 hours
last night i slept eight hours
i've always slept six or seven except
for extreme traveling which was
occasional
again this is where this is where
you realize the world is a headline
reading society not an actual article
reading society
people would hear one quote from one
keynote and make an assumption
when i am fueled by gratitude and
happiness which gives me high energy
when i'm awake
i like to be efficient when i'm awake
but
i've long said weekends i'm checked out
seven weeks of vacation
i i sleep plenty it's just i think that
i'm very high energy when i'm awake
because i'm happy because i love it
but then how do you get everything done
like do you ever get overwhelmed
is there is there ever stressed out
anxious gary vee
like and how do you deal with those
moments depressed stephen
there's not a the only time i'm stressed
out depressed
anxious businessman gary vee is when
people aren't treating each other well
in my organization it kills me
culture that stresses the [ __ ] out of me
i got a
text last night around a brush up of two
employees at 10 50
and it took me 10 minutes to be that
upsets me
but getting a text that says xyz client
fired us for a million dollars
doesn't even register getting a text we
didn't win the business doesn't
the money part [ __ ] the money part the
the happiness part it was the same
reason i was bad at candor
i don't like negativity so i wasn't able
to
lead with candor i don't like negativity
around people so when they're fighting
with each other i get upset
we need to that's why i spend so much
time on hr i
i'm doing what i'm good at and what i
love there's people that don't get
anxious when they ski
when they garden there's people who
don't get anxious and aren't upset and
never burn out from playing tennis
or golf my love is my work
i i as a kid i shoveled snow
i washed cars i had you know lemonade
stands i did baseball cards
i this is the thing that people haven't
connected yet there's a group of us
who just love the process of doing
business it's more it's not about the
money
it's about the game the way people look
at gardening and skiing
and swimming and yeah it's your flow
that's what you're saying it's like
where you find your flow i'll give you
an example
my mother's flow is being a mother
my sister was anxious being a mother
because her flow was also working but
she thought you had to stay home like my
mom
once my sister created balance between
now she's a real estate agent and a
mother
she's in her flow so for my mom being a
mom
24 7 was sheer happiness no exhaustion
for my sister because it wasn't purity
an hour of laundry was devastating
for for a lot of people that work it's
not their flow so it's terrible for me
it's my flow so so as we enter this
i think this new time where mental
health is at you know is in the focus
right everyone's working from home
um there's a lot of burnout happening
how do you
make sure that employees feel like
they're seen
and heard and you create a good
corporate culture where wellness is
integrated
is that possible by by seeing
them and hearing them we
reinforce our unlimited vacation policy
we
we talk to our managers about not
creating unconscious
bias and subconscious bias around people
taking time
which is huge uh we're implementing a
really interesting thing i own i own a
site 137pm.com please everybody go check
it out
a young male media site to complement
purewow.com that i bought
we are now going to be implementing
january 1st the first time i'm saying
this my employees don't even know
uh at 1 37 p.m eastern every single day
we're gonna be doing a guest 15 minute
speaker that's going to come in on zoom
and
what i'm what the reason i'm doing it
for 15 minutes is if i do it at 1 37 pm
and sometimes it's shaq and sometimes
it's shira and sometimes it's somebody
else
coming in whatever they're talking about
for 15 minutes if it's at 1 37 p.m my
hope is that that means at 1 30 to 1 37
people will take two seconds and just
recalibrate because people are just
going zoom
right you know yeah so i'm hoping to
break up patterns right then then the
15-minute talk you got another eight
minutes so i'm hoping and by the way
they don't even have to tune in for the
15 minute keynote so
i'm almost mandating a 30 30 minute
break
with this concept so you're doing some
things from the top but most of all what
you're doing
is you're reminding people that life is
a self-awareness game
that a lot of people are blaming
companies but it's actually their own
insecurities that they were parented on
that are manifesting through the way
they're handling their work so we want
to blame
technology we want to blame the bosses
we want to blame the government
but what it really is is how we were
parented and who we actually
are because we have anxiety everywhere
we're just bringing ourselves to work
this world is just exposing us
technology is exposing us
more so than it's changing us people
want to go there because they don't want
the accountability
it's more fun to blame than to be
accountable
shira it is more fun to blame pointing
fingers
is a [ __ ] load more exciting for people
than pointing thumbs
pointing fingers is a lot more fun than
pointing thumbs
and the more you point thumbs and take
on accountability and do self-reflection
and self-awareness and then deploy
self-love
and realize other people have
shortcomings too then you can get to a
place
then the blame game is a depressing game
yeah not i mean you're preaching to the
choir here
i i agree and then my hope is that we
can all come together um
to make sure we're all seeing that
because you know it it takes
a village it takes a community to make
change right right now
yes we do have questions real quick but
the biggest part
part of the community is you with
yourself
you you lead by example it starts with
you yeah it's it's
you know if you're gonna have help you
need to help yourself first
and you need to create a framework that
allows others to help and that
needs in its core foundation
accountability
and i'm telling you that is a huge
unlock anyway
keep going i want to know when where you
discovered all this stuff
if you did it in therapy or through your
own work or what happened
i think i think my mom parented me in a
way i think being an immigrant and not
having much
my circumstance created it i think i
think
therapy and just thoughtfulness i'm an
observer by nature which has made me
good
in what i do but that also allows me to
observe
bigger things i think caring about it
you know again i think
when when when people realize that it's
not about the money
it's not about the accolades when i do
this keynote as incredibly humbling as
it is to be a keynote here and do this
fireside
i'm coming into this with the mindset of
say one thing
that starts the process for one person
to get to a better happier place
that when that's your kpi everything
changes
okay well speaking of which we do have a
lot of questions i want to get to them
because we don't have a lot of time we
can continue talking about this forever
i love it
so one question what can virtual event
organizers learn from twitch
are you into twitch right now i am into
twitch i remember the day one from
justin tv
uh i'm actually wearing a version one
hat the esports team i own with the
minnesota viking owners
uh the wilfs in this arena um what they
can learn is that
is that iconic pillars of culture can
pop up at any time
let me remind people that hip hop is a
modern day
phenomenon esports
ufc mixed martial arts these are three
major things in our
influencers on social media all four of
the things i just mentioned
non-existent 40 years ago didn't exist
so the biggest thing you can learn from
twitch it's success
it's success and people being into
esports
is in the rest of our lives there will
be
many things that come along that right
this second do not exist
and become an entertainment and escapism
a framework that impacts billions
i love that do you think uh virtual
events are just going to grow
right now or are we going to get sick of
them i think virtual events are going to
evolve
in a great way i i i think there's gonna
be mixed
i think real life events with virtual
elements are so cool imagine a week's
worth of virtual events leading up to
the weekend
that the real thing happens imagine
imagine being at the real thing and
there's virtual ones going on at the
same time
um i think virtual events themselves and
uh halo
are gonna incorporate people more like
for example i wish i could see 75
people's faces even if they were small
boxes right now on the right side
the chat stream for me that's good
because i'm chaos improv for other
people that would distract them but give
me the option
you know so i think there's gonna be
innovation yeah chaos improv
that's that's a new one i haven't heard
before uh so this one uh how do you see
business marketing strategy change in
this pandemic climate also do you
predict a major
uh swift shift to cater to the new
generation how
well i think the shift of new generation
is happening
therefore like the world's being forced
into this not the other way around you
know the ogs
have not been able to convince people to
watch more television and
read more newspapers and listen to more
radio they would have chosen to they've
had to adapt
to podcasting social mobile
yeah all right we have uh someone i i
keep thinking there's me a name but it's
all anonymous
uh what do you do in your company to
move people away from blame to
accountability and you talked about it
but like when you see someone doing that
what do you actually say to them
like how do you manage that we we
historically managed with sunshine and
honey
and deliciousness hey shira hey listen
you know like hey you know like you know
sometimes in meetings you know you know
when you start talking over
carol who's on her first day you're
really creating a fear-based
you know like hey just give it some
thought and i would do that four times
what i'm trying to become now is do that
the first time but the second time
saying look shira
you were politically undermining people
in rooms you are
making people feel insecure and you're
hurting the culture and the company now
has to overthink
how to manage you in meetings versus
actually work on the work so to be very
frank with you this is a warning
and if the behavior continues you're not
going to be here and by the way i love
you like you've done a great job to get
to this point and you were a great
executor but now as a manager you have
some shortcomings
and i think it's around insecurity how
do i make you feel safer
but you cannot make people feel this way
so that's that's the evolution
hey looks like you've practiced that i
love that um
you mentioned that you keep an eye on
anything that reduces friction or
anything that makes things faster but
how do you balance this out with the
growing hypotheses that
human-centered design leads to harmful
companies
that i think the conversation around
harmful companies is
immature i think we're in the phase
right now of the demonization
you know the social dilemma this that
the other thing
the reality is is
we are struggling with adding the second
part of accountability
if you if you do not like what a
platform is doing
for you because of its lack of friction
you can you can unsubscribe it
i equate this conversation to alcoholism
you know we've had a very mature we're
now very deep
in alcohol culture that where now we
talk about
it is a disease for some people it is
which
deserves a certain way to be dealt with
however
the majority of people are capable of
finding their balance
everybody here if they're so unhappy and
insecure
can delete instagram off their phone
when i was growing up
magazines were bad guys and girls
because they were showing kate moss at
85 pounds and every girl was throwing up
in their bathroom to look like it
right so we were demonizing that
platform we have
a very immature conversation around
social networks right now where
it was nirvana when you and i were there
early right utopia
now it's massively demonized thing the
answer is absolutely
in the middle and it centers around
accountability
like parents that allow their children
to be in the room locked in the room
for 15 hours want to blame the phone how
about you actually communicate with your
child
and you take time out of your day to
actually have a relationship with your
child
instead of blaming snapchat you know
it's it's fascinating
and that's why so what do i think i
think that people
uh we have this conversation around fast
food
fast food is inexpensive it's very
convenient
and our society has learned how to
balance
when to eat chicken nuggets and when not
to
and so this notion that woe is me this
machine these evil people behind
this algorithm are ruining society
these platforms are exposing us they're
not
changing us to agree that people want
people just don't like what they see
when we get unveiled true and i think
the more we've even held fast food
companies accountable they've even
decided to step up because
if you don't call people out they can be
like you know how it works it's like i
just
keep going yeah but like here's how they
step
up they show you how many calories it is
which is amazing and i'm excited about
that
i'm i'm thrilled for every social media
post to say be careful don't use too
much time i'm thrilled if apple wants to
shut down my phone
after eight hours yeah except if i want
to except if i want to use it for nine
hours
what people right now are asking for in
censorship they don't realize it
instead of accountability they want
government interference
or like for these companies to be held
accountable you want somebody to be held
accountable
start with your [ __ ] self first
and what if you've done that and then
it's still a [ __ ] show excuse my
language
then you go to the modern conversation
thank god that therapy is not
the stigma that it was 50 years ago
the meaning it still should you outside
of you meaning the world around you
like you know i i'm going to show shira
like i was born in a communist country
like this
you know this entitlement that the world
should be like there's always going to
be stuff
we have to think about what we can do
about things
you can control your household tobacco
companies have huge warnings on them now
you know it's about education you know
so what so what let's stop using our
phones so we can just sit in front of
the television
like yo like like people like like you
need to be educating that taking a hike
or meditating or drinking water like you
you the information's out there the
information's out there you have to seek
it
you have to want to change
yeah i mean i think yeah and we get into
this also this is like so many
interesting
um kind of conversations because i agree
but i think the more it becomes the norm
to ask for those things the more people
are pushing for it and leading by
example then
corporate culture kind of steps in and
goes they realize they need to do it too
so it's like it kind of works in a
balance like in a relationship right
it needs to be symbiotic
yeah but corporate follows humans
if everyone becomes avail you know
everyone talks
all this talk on keyboard warriors but
their actions are different
americans are about to not vote in a
week
vote by the way if you're in the us who
have talked nothing but unlimited
amounts of [ __ ] in either the left or
right direction for months and will not
vote on tuesday
the hypocrisy in human society today
is laughable accountability will help so
many people
go ahead so what do you think of
companies making statements supporting
activism that may not be genuine how can
companies promote transparency and
empathy in these efforts without
sounding like they are just jumping on
the bad
bandwagon for sales and i'm sure you
probably dealt with this with companies
you worked with as
this whole summer yeah nobody cares
about your facebook ban
if you're not doing the right like it's
just so silly the answer to the question
is a great one
by living the truth don't you're way
better off not saying something
if you're not there than saying
something and being half pregnant or
being fake
it's like whenever make a statement
that's right that's right
gary besides being a jets fan what has
been the worst investment of your time
by the way i love the person i asked
that let me just tell everybody if you
want an insight to me being a jets fan
has been the greatest investment of my
time
because i actually enjoyed the journey
back to everything we've been talking
about for the last 45 minutes
um i don't think of i don't think of
things as wasted time you know
uh if you talk in money standpoint i
spent the first 13 years of my life
building an enormous business for my dad
and left with nothing
nothing you know like how to start
vaynermedia in a conference room at
buddy media because
i not only did i build a huge business
for him if i wasn't a family member i
would have at least got paid well
you know for building something from 3
to 65 million when you build a family
business for your parent
you're not making a lot of money because
nobody does in a family business because
the business is the other child
and so you know but i think of that as
the greatest use of my time my dad is
gonna die one day
and i'm gonna sit there after my massive
cry session and say thank you god
thank you god for letting me work in
that store from 14 to 34 so much
i have so many more memories than my
brother and sister have or that i could
have
and so i think it all depends on how
people think about wasted time i think
0.0 about waste of time i fear not i do
not fear wasting a second
i like to be efficient but i never
critique what i did
as a waste of time because it gave me
experiences happiness escapism
financial they all go in different
buckets there is no wasted time if you
choose to not think of it that way
what are three things you wish you knew
when you were starting vaynermedia
that's a great question i wish i knew
something about the advertising industry
because i came in raw
raw i i i you know what's funny
let me go let me answer this differently
most of things that i didn't know became
my advantages when i started vayner
because i did media and creative
together which is clearly the answer to
the digital age
i hired non-agency people that didn't
come with baggage
the the things that i didn't realize was
that people had disciplines like
strategy creative account
and i thought to omni i thought
everybody could do everything and that
that wasted some time but not really
because i learned from it and we are who
we are
today um
those those are the themes more so than
three things i wish
yeah do you think instagram reels is the
same opportunity for organic as compared
with tick-tock
what do you think of all these new
features instagram always comes out just
to compete with other
companies i i think it's smart i think i
think instagram
if instagram didn't come out with
stories snapchat would be the biggest
platform in the world
i think it's smart yeah i mean igtv
yeah you know this year like they don't
all hit but let's not be confused
instagram stories disproportionately
changed the outcome of instagram and
snapchat
and so for facebook inc that was good i
think reels has
more organic upside within the instagram
ecosystem
ironically something i mean my team i
was making fun of myself with my team
two days ago
because i don't make as many reels as i
should i don't even really have
the full answer yet but it within the
instagram ecosystem i do think it has
more potential i don't think
it has more potential than tick tock as
a macro so i would answer no i don't
think so
what do you think about the trend of
internalization of ad agencies services
within companies
i think it's going to evan flow i think
you know brands are going to build
internal shops they're going to realize
that the strengths and weaknesses of
them and i think you'll see
uh brands have mixes of external and
internal partnerships
um and so i think it will ebb and flow
i already have clients who've already
shut down their internal shops i have
clients that are asking us to build
their internal shops
in conjunction with us having some fees
and i have some clients starting the
process of building their own internal
shops
and i expect that to always be a
constant ebb and flow within every
organization in perpetuity
um someone said love the mission-driven
dtc comment what stage do you invest at
that's a great question i go with the
gamut i'll go a or proceed excuse me if
you show me an entrepreneur where she's
already done something twice
and this is her third rodeo and she's
done it successfully twice and she's the
most passionate about peanut butter
you'll see me write a check before she's
done with her pitch i'll also
pass some things in series b because i'm
like they're just running math arbitrage
they don't have the creative
layer they definitely aren't building
brand so i'm agnostic
on when i'll come in i'm just looking
for certain characteristics
um someone says i'm a huge fan of yours
what advice would you give to a 37 year
old mom of three who just finished her
degree and wants a career change where
do i
start linkedin make unlimited content on
linkedin of your opinions and
observations of the new industry you
want to be in
whether it's in video written form
linkedin organic reach is working
you may say one thing that catches the
eye of one recruiter or one executive
and change the course of your life
this is back to two thousand 2007 89
social media when it was all utopia
one piece of content can change the
course of your life please go on
linkedin if you're trying to change your
career
and make your observation around the
movie industry around the ski industry
scratch your own itch what do you see
wrong write a manifesto make a video
one piece of linkedin content is
all it takes for you to actually change
your career at 37.
how are you working with your company
and other companies on equity and
inclusion right now
uh dictatorship i used to hate crete
creating status
uh quotas i thought that if you looked
at the history of colleges and other
institutions doing it
left a lot to be left desired however
we we are mandating dni in
in levels in c suite and you know in
bringing consultants uh from c suite to
entry level
mandating a certain level of dni because
it was proven to me that the company
even with my intent even with claude
silver's intent even with
all the dni leaders we had we were
unable to
be phenomenal at it we could be we were
in the 10 years we were
solid at it sometimes remarkable
sometimes atrocious
and and i need a steady flow just like i
need in finance to make sure that the
pnl is balanced
i need a steady flow and so i've been
interviewing chief diversity officers
who will have a very big remit and a
very big seat at the table and so
it's it's been a really fun process to
be frank uh through the
interview process and i'm still in it as
we speak and while i've been doing that
i've been mandating a level of
really on the women front of the latino
front on other parts we were really
in a phenomenal shape we were not where
we need to be on a black front and
that's what we're addressing now
yeah i think that's accountability yeah
right it goes to accountability like
i went on a zoom in front of the whole
company look whether it's bad stacks in
the cafeteria or it's not enough black
leaders 100
of this is on me because i've empowered
the people to take care of this
i made that choice so i think it starts
with accountability and i think it
starts with action
and uh and so i'm excited about it like
boehner speakers
black diversity was through the roof my
investments are through the roof but
vayner wasn't at the
enough of the right place and i think
there's some macro issues with
advertising but that's the excuse
everyone uses we're just hiring from
outside of advertising if we have to and
that's what we're doing
that's awesome as we wrap things up is
there anything else you want to share
with everyone here at c2 today
yes creative and media together
to create insights is the missing
element for so many of you
please my incredible art people don't
demonize
math and analytics please my incredibly
smart math people
stop making fun of creative without the
harmony of the two
and without the humility of listening to
the end consumer to then help you
ideate above and beyond it you will
become a dinosaur
and and when i think about this the
iconics the people i put on huge
pedestals
sid lee's widens crisp
there's so much incredible talent but
there's a need for contemporary humility
and process for there to be prosperity
over the next decade and whether you're
a brand
a dtc brand an agency person humility
and curiosity
need to become foundational in the
creative process
right now it's audacious political um
and and there's a lot left to be desired
i would argue the creative agency
landscape
is the least creative industry i've come
across in my 25 years
which is just devastating because the
humans in it
started off incredibly creative but the
machine
sucked the creativity out of them and
the audacity of creative directors
imposing their will on junior creatives
being the judge in the jury there's just
so many dynamics that could be better
they say things like good ideas can come
from anywhere but the process doesn't
allow it
there just there's so much opportunity
please let's make the creative industry
creative again
i love that well gary vaynerchuk thank
you so much it's been such a pleasure
and honor to speak to you here today on
c2 and to everyone who watch from around
the world
thank you we so appreciate you again you
know where to follow him at garyvee
i'm at shira lazar yes this has been
awesome so thank you so much
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon